hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to stick bold a dodgeball
adventure hi hi we actually have done
both oh sorry did you wanna say I was
too slow I missed it too slow window
comes by and goes no more caller hi hi
I'll be ready next time there's not
gonna be a next time okay
what are we just going oh oh oh
witch what who oh that was the interim
Oh lovely
Wow what I am second player I am NOT in
this keyboard and mouse is also a player
that's good I am blue I am boring I'm
red that's is terribly wrong Juliet is
tough we'll have to deal with it I don't
even know how to play I want pots
yeah one ridiculously difficult boss
what do it why oh oh god she looks
terrifying and we're gonna play and hell
yes okay why did they play dodgeball I
look at points to win so who knows what
you think it said three okay alright so
we've got two hats or something I'm a
goddamn edge go how'd she go wow that's
not love triggers done what what did you
put on a heart like us she's not me why
isn't angel doing music laugh laughing
[Music]
or but on a really [ __ ] robot who's
now fine hey oh my god oh god yeah Oh L
stood on me
eyes did you I did you left trigger and
wrench with your right you're gonna grab
left take trigger to drive dive dip ah
option
go [ __ ] dammit there's a body so [ __ ]
no but you know what don't give it about
Apple boy lover
what Oh God oh [ __ ] ah you gotta Bob you
got Bob nice you know
Oh Bob you guys don't try to love a bomb
that was almost here Bob I thought it
was gonna be sure that wah wah wah
well what are we playing - what could
she when she [ __ ] wins oh yeah don't
get me happy for people every once in a
while it's that person not a person is
it okay are you laughing love dead
alright so now we're gonna play for real
not against a bot we're still learning
we're gonna be very forgiving on each
other and gonna be fun time we're here
yeah I'll show your basic stuff the
chimp seems like the place basics I'm
right again yee-haa me Carson until
green all right I'm still blue I'm the
first one out and the last one leave
ah oh yeah woo [ __ ] I go to try and
[ __ ] get no hot cheese hey pervy Dave
oh come on hey he's a Buddhist cries I
I'm doing really good guys you're not a
person fuel your that's really harsh man
yeah
Ron Ewing you're just a boy huh gotcha
oh [ __ ] nope cheese yeah oh god yeah
anyway hey doing leg good or you know Oh
have a good time wait
what could I do
god damn it did you see me no dude came
back
oh no on a floor washer Oh weird
yeah you didn't notice me riding floor
was that you coming after us yeah oh we
all missed it there's like a there's
like a unique bounce there no other well
they're buttons for this now I [ __ ]
dodged oh come on
yeah would you throw Honda I did what
you what if you if you dive at the hot
dogger [ __ ] you nice one me I just cover
Kazi in there God Jesus Christ I'm so
mad right now
okay I think my guy just got naked and
charged it he doesn't laughing you like
when you're dead you can come back oh I
like dying now not DS ha what oh it just
interrupt yeah come on up
how'd you get a hooked up oh you got
after yeah hey let me see what box
excuse ha ha ha you got my Jesus Christ
it's Oh actually kills ya Wow hot dog
ah man no one he's on a mission
ah no holy [ __ ] ha ha ha ah my butt baby
look out here come Oh
ha good grab a blood this is [ __ ] how
do you do that a right trigger right
look out here comes mighty o holy
ah no oh my god that prosciutto brochure
god [ __ ] damn it
hi this tuna tuna - is coming in for the
interference with the love hugs
oh I know I had to get there fast all
right it's all tied up next point wins
Oh God what oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] no [ __ ]
you guys
goddamn it no whoa did you know I hit
the hotdog man his cart exploded and
then my cover was gone and you hit me
the comeback ah I don't think I hate
your thing you've already given the
glory oh oh yeah [ __ ] yeah
oh those be the guy hit that smart oh my
god jeez like if I dodge before you
shoot no I die I gotta be I'm comin I
hate you so much
ah the bees got me to go I hate all of
you so much
I'm sorry ball house not me though I do
not be you beast me
they're just bees in the gut so I went
for why every time looking it Oh what
they don't stick to you
oh shut up
I was actually hoping to fight back oh
[Applause]
you get B's all these all the beat is
[ __ ] goddamn it ah well I got one of
the bees
ah HUD so after the bees hit me that
time they went away I don't understand
why they er time oh my god
oh [ __ ] you know it all comes down to
this your couple of goofs
Oh what the goose Monica
that was lucky you gotta imagine like
people played on while having a good
time ha ha got ya yeah I was a $2.00 mom
came back violin dude the strategy is
just to stay away from everyone and
huncles why are we naked I don't know
anything to do or the Jews of each time
all right well you you one wrong you one
one I've gotta win marks turn [ __ ]
bugs and let me win oh oh [ __ ] the crown
god damn it the [ __ ] how do I God God
she'd the sand balls itch no show your
engine oh crap oh [ __ ] I'm so distracted
by the goddamn oh I didn't even shoot
Margaret in still yeah I had that the
beginning of the game it's nice crabs
confirm whatever you just got to run
away man yeah you gotta grab this no you
guys just kill the show of each other oh
crap oh god oh god
whoa what I understand why why did it go
Wow
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] you crap no oh the amount of
constancy No
all right ah oh yes yes [ __ ] there
some warning for that yeah you see the
fan you're the facetious Christ stay
away from the edge of people in bed I
still understand I don't think I've ever
actually oh I looked up ahead Oh No oh
ho jeez I don't think I ever have yet I
did the father I'm glad that happen to
someone for [ __ ] else oh Jesus come
on Bob
I got your babymoon all the way oh
that's it whoo I get to decide who's
gonna win here yeah wait wait who's your
friend who's your friend wave it who's
always nice to you Oh apparently the tow
jeez well I was exciting
well alright man watch out for that
Beach I don't [ __ ] I can't do that
dude dude oh god why ain't the beach
ball Oh from behind Highland one hitch
aren't you sure why can't you just ate
the bait it'll randomly it's random oh
nice so I got double shark randomly and
Marky didn't win your match all right
one more one more alright hell yeah
those holes no they're not holes okay
we're good oh drift okay I got the ball
oh oh oh hey for once it wasn't [ __ ]
me I'm gonna [ __ ] you buddy
here we go what're gonna come do not
take advantage that way
ah take that bomb where is that well you
guys just ride it out you guys just
fight it out that's fine
what what am i God you fell off I feel
well don't weigh on me bro damage [ __ ]
Christ
kill someone else when you're dead Jesus
yeah every time - ha ha ha you already
hurt almost unheard [ __ ] thank God I
was expecting the next world it's in me
like my ball Oh [ __ ] what's [ __ ] over
you oh no no that's fine
you guys just hang out over there and
play with him by yourself no oh my god
were you trying to get me or you just
[ __ ] around I was trying to get Baldy
you went in there from LA I was like I
just gotta kill him before more kills me
I know it's coming it's gonna happen not
always you wait
[ __ ] me over this wow that's yeah
alright you're good you're getting
wheeled got Tim and now [ __ ] you I will
you know come on yeah no no come on yeah
no I can't get you hahaha yeah okay
how did I get wailed all the time yeah
how did you that's really amazing
actually
[ __ ] thumbs up yeah yeah how do you
catch it like I don't know dive into it
in the air is the only way I've caught
it with leg up will you well I get Bob
gets it again
neat yeah where are you where we
shooting there come on bub bub oh no no
no no
oh [ __ ] me oh so anti-climax
weren't you on magic point - yeah he was
at dammit I want any of these no it's
been too and to which I'd record some
yeah I would I would that's the spirit
yo started off with me being good at
destroying the hardball we're back we're
back here al where we belong hell this
marks domain how like [ __ ] turn up
oh how did I miss oh oh yeah go in that
lava way that's good yeah [ __ ] that's
bitchin
oh why don't I so small
Oh God
Oh God Bob I always respected you Bob Oh
God come on Bosco Bernard how many
[ __ ] wives do you have
what can we do gotta get away right how
many lives do we have you got it like
through this phone doors go away girls
go away yeah you said to stay alive till
those stars all go away
I got damnit [ __ ] Wade ah no oh you
didn't oh no got an onion okay yeah wait
I gotta go I gotta get it
chica go why didn't you did super dammit
gosh [ __ ] my guy doesn't turn like that
huh when you what I try and turn it
never turns before I shoot it
oh no that's weird are they I'm just bad
at timing gonna see your [ __ ] hiding
spots ah worth it again what ha ha did
you push me in I don't know I I didn't
go in that time oh wow what oh come on I
died for that head oh I'm [ __ ] with
Wade [ __ ] wood what why oh ah
let's go good hunter have them hey come
get the [ __ ] tell me the [ __ ] ball
[ __ ] oh no no no my god whew that was a
bull diet Oh push people baby boy oh my
twin guys oh no no no what
we can't get him get him get under me
why do you mean
still what how is that working together
oh I don't know I guess I wasn't paying
attention to another party oh you a
little like I'm over you you got him ah
do it do it [ __ ] do it okay the best
I buy at noon
you're the worst teammate oh Jesus
Christ
yes I run into her you only hit me you
all know angel the plate on him okay we
can end there great cut out the wrong
mark one no don't do that make it seem
like I won every round let's move a lot
of work play around normally then after
they win just have me go wow so fun my
Christ I was a crazy game have an anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
this was way more fun than I thought it
was gonna be in way more competitive so
thank you Bob and waited for joining me
hope your voices no that's trash yeah
but I hope you enjoyed this little move
I hope you enjoyed it let us know what
you thought of it down in the comments
below and check out their channels in
the description thanks again everybody
for watching as always
Oh in the next video bye
[Music]